avec nous nathalie grandvaux qui est
directrice du laboratoire de recherche
sur la réponse de l'autre aux infections
virales au centre de recherche du chum
madame gravaud bonsoir bonsoir que
signifie cette avancée aujourd'hui un
vaccin en phase iii efficace à 90 pour
ça écoutez ces essais de la lumière au
bout du tunnel bien entendu il faut
rester prudent quand même il ya beaucoup
de choses encore à vérifier puis à
confirmer premièrement de voir les
données les vraiment donné qu'ils ont
pas encore été publié mais c'est ce que
ça donne beaucoup d'espoir sur la
capacité de générer un vaccin efficace
et donc ses premières données et sont
vraiment très très encourageante est
très intéressant
l'épidémiologiste leur chef aux
etats-unis le docteur anthony fao tu
disais que 50 60 % d'efficacité
ce serait bien alors à 90% est ce qu'on
est au-delà des attentes d'un cissé si
ces chiffres se confirment jusqu'à la
fin de l'étude elle est l'étude de phase
iii est pas terminée le nombre le les
critères pour le nombre de patients
étudiés mais pour que la f10 et approuve
le vaccin n'est pas encore atteint mais
si ce chiffre se maintient jusqu'à la
fin ça serait le meilleur scénario ça
serait vraiment exceptionnel pour pour
ce qui est d'un vaccin de ce genre là
effectivement et à quel moment
le vaccin sera étaient disponibles donc
dans ces circonstances ça dépend de nous
on parle pour l'instant en fait si le
vaccin remplit tous les critères pour
que la f10 et puissent donner une
approbation d'urgence qui devrait
arriver dans le site où tout va bien là
selon ce que pfizer a annoncé
aujourd'hui que tous les résultats sont
conformes
ça se révèle dans le mois de décembre
donc ils ont annoncé qu'ils pouvaient
fabriquer 50 millions de doses d'ici la
fin de l'année ce qui veut dire la
capacité de vacciner 25 millions de
personnes donc très certainement vu que
le vaccin n'est pas produit au canada on
ne seraient pas les premiers à avoir les
premières doses donc là il faut voir
quand est ce que nous on va recevoir les
premières doses qui ont été réservées
par le gouvernement canadien
monsieur trudeau on a parlé aujourd'hui
il parlait du premier trimestre de 2021
à partir de là quand est ce qu'on va
pouvoir
vraiment vacciner les gens c'est le
meilleur des scénarios
ça serait vers la fin du printemps ou et
vers la fin de l'hiver début du
printemps
moi je penche plus pour le mois de mai
compte tenu de toute la logistique qui
entoure les doses et que le nombre de
doses va être limité au départ nous
sommes en novembre
vous parlez de décembre pour les
premiers vaccins qui pourrait être donc
prêt début 2021
ensuite pour avoir des vaccins
distribués par exemple aux états unis
mais chez nous faudra attendre jusqu'au
mois de mai mais écoutez c'est difficile
à dire parce qu'on sait pas à quel
rythme les doses mon être produite par
par pfizer et les gens qui travaillent
avec eux mais si si j'en crois ce qui
était dit aujourd'hui par monsieur
trudeau ça serait des livraisons
potentiellement pour le mois de mars à
peu près donc
ensuite une fois qu'on les a reçus il
faut organiser la distribution fait que
on peut aussi on pourrait être optimiste
si tout va extrêmement bien pour un
petit peu plus tôt mais j'aurais
tendance à penser que ça prend de
l'organisation et que si on est capable
de le faire au mois de mai on va être
déjà très en très bonne position
fin octobre le docteur horacio arruda
espérer avoir vaccins au québec et au
canada en janvier ou en février
est ce que c'est quand même toujours
possible de recevoir les premières doses
peut être de là à faire de la
distribution et de la vaccination dans
le public peut-être pas ça probablement
pas je pense que ça reste très optimiste
mais il a peut-être des informations sur
la distribution qui est déjà organisée
que qui nous a pas partagés
ça serait une belle nouvelle mais j'ai
très peur je serai prudente pour pour
cet élément est le vaccin une fois
injecté le docteur faraci dit je ne sais
pas combien de temps il va durer
est ce que c'est ça la grande la grande
question sur la suite des choses
ça fait partie des questions
effectivement quand on fait l'étude de
phase iii la sq kaiser a annoncé c'est
que les patients qu'ils ont analysé pour
l'instant ont été vaccinées il ya deux
mois donc on a deux mois d'étude de
connaissance de la protection pour en
savoir plus sur la durée de cette
protection
il va falloir que c'est
six ans vaccinée continue de vivre soit
soumis en fait a rencontré le virus
c'est voir combien de temps ils sont
protégés donc l'étude ne s'arrête pas à
partir du moment où la distribution va
se faire on va continuer de cataloguer
en fait un certain nombre d'informations
qui vont nous permettre de savoir quelle
est la durée protection et s'il faut
comme ça existe et pour d'autres vaccins
il y aura des rappels de vaccination si
on voit que dans le temps la
l'immunisation ne persiste pas est ce
que pour vous parisien est aujourd'hui
clairement en avance sur les autres
grandes entreprises comme comme modern
art qui doit aussi annoncer des
résultats quand même bientôt écouter oui
ils ont un petit peu d'avancé parce
qu'ils ont réussi à compléter le las
d'avoir suffisamment de patients dans
leurs études rapidement maintenant il ya
plusieurs vaccins qui sont en phase 3
dont moderna que vous avez mentionné
ils devraient avoir leurs premiers
résultats préliminaires équivalent à
celui trailer dans les prochaines
semaines on les attendait aussi à pour
la femme à mai donc ça va se suivre à
pas grand chose puis ça va nous donner
beaucoup plus d'options si jamais il
arrive avec des résultats positifs aussi
il utilise une technologie qui est très
proche de celle de pfizer et c'est
surtout la même cible alors je pense que
c'est l'autre bonne nouvelle de des
résultats de pfizer aujourd'hui c'est
que la cible est la bonne beaucoup de on
a eu beaucoup de questions départ de
savoir si tous les yeux étaient même mis
dans le même panier mais ça semble que
ça soit une bonne cible donc ça donne de
l'optimisme pour tous les autres vaccins
candidats en cours de développement
absolument
madame bravo merci pour cette analyse et
explications ce soir merci à vous